how much of the math did you actually
understand who is the best out of the
class in applying the mask and are you
better sodoku now what was the last part
of question are you buried oku now
what's that
are you Barrett said okey now am I was
better it's Doku thank you I can't even
hear so I'm gonna be good a stoker no no
no we we had one day we all thought oh
yeah we should really be doing
crosswords so we brought in like the
quick quick crossword there were five of
us
and it took us five days and we still
get proficient so no we're really bad at
all of it and I didn't understand any of
the math did you don't say you did that
opens up kind of trouble yeah that's it
why I remember we were there we had this
specialist was trying to describe this
wonderful machine Alan Turing god bless
you yeah Bletchley Park almost August I
mean every nice face it's just how many
thousands of times we broaden you had
the all this expert and it was flying
and be just listening and NBC this panic
the eyes of everybody were looking at it
like this is this is impossible is that
feeling I haven't had since school being
in massive just like you sort of feel
that you've died and there's no way to
concentrate at all it was that and I'm
desperately fighting cuz he was such a
nice man you go this is really
interesting I should be paying attention
and I couldn't you know there's a great
broad romance the road to the philosophy
of maths and physics which is dramatized
these days which is which is tangible
hopefully because otherwise there is no
point in explaining it all it's sharing
it with an audience and I think there
are hugely exciting things that on a
base level everyone can understand the
idea of coding the idea of programming
the idea that what we use is language
can be turned into something universal
and could be used in a machine here
China Russia you know your wherever and
and those things excite me you know the
fact that my eyelashes carbon in it from
a star excites me I don't necessarily
understand everything about how to make
an eyelash but it's the broad
brushstrokes are very appealing and I
you know as far as the Machine goes D
machine the bomb
Christopher an arse but the bomb in
reality at Bletchley Park that was the
moment
right now this time this is very hard
and the guy the guys Dan advisor took
can you explain it to me just look Tim
you in right so what we have here and
you lose Damian if you knew it was not
just me not just a stupid actor but also
the fact that every other person isn't
necessarily a pure math expert a
mechanical engineer or a combination of
the two these are incredibly complex
machines breaking down incredibly
complex problems at great high level and
sorry high place and high volume and you
know as I understood a little bit about
it I did understand it but I understood
a lot about the Enigma machine the
absolute coding machine and but yeah if
you put it algorithm in front of me now
I offered even a quadratic equation
would have this press conference going
far too long no [ __ ]
you